hello everyone my name is simone
siverini and i am the director of the
quantum computing team at amazon i'm
joined today by
six of my colleagues to discuss the
field of quantum computing how they got
started in the field and what's to come
in the future thanks for joining all
so i want to start our conversation by
by getting grounded
on all your origin stories so tell me
more about your career path and and what
led you to pursuing the field of quantum
computing
so maybe i can start some money
so i started i
um so if i trace things back right with
the benefit of hindsight my my interest
really started
as a kid i was very interested in
mathematics and reading uh
little things and i read about these
things called trapdoor functions which
are operations that are very hard to do
in one direction but very easy in
another direction and i read about it it
was super cool and i forgot about it
then i went on to do a
a degree in physics and eventually i
when i was doing a uh a postgraduate i
read about this thing called shore's
algorithm which has an intimate
connection to these trapdoors functions
and and i thought oh that is really
really cool but i really liked optics so
i went on to do a postgraduate in optics
and then i heard about this thing called
quantum key distribution that really
tied in together all my interest between
mathematics and security and physics and
optics and and i knew really that i had
i had found my path and since then i you
know i did a phd in oxford making
entanglement sources and i moved to
santa barbara then i went on to start
something in singapore
and eventually i ended up here in aws
so where did you where did you
read about
trapdoor functions
oh so scientific american used to have
these these little
um
little mathematical puzzles call them i
can't remember what it was called but
they had this uh
a guy called uh uh martin gardner that
published these things and these things
get got compiled i mean this was before
my my time but they got compiled into
books and
one of these books was lying around in
my house and i i devoured those things
so
right that was it
tell us about your your interest in
quantum computing please
thanks amani so
as a kid i grew up on a mix of
programming a zx spectrum playing lots
of dungeons and dragons and doing nerdy
things like watching too much science
fiction
and for me that kind of like mixture of
science technology and magical thinking
seems to lead me to doing a degree at
bristol in physics and philosophy
and then throughout my uh degree bristol
quantum physics was by far the most
fascinating subject both on the physics
side but also on the philosophy side
um but then after the end when it came
to the end of my degree i kind of
thought i wanted to carry on exploring
this weird world of quantum physics but
i also wanted to do something
practical that would have an impact on
technology
and to kind of
revive and reconnect with this childhood
interest i had in computers and so
quantum computing was the obvious choice
right so you see it's interesting that
antia interest in science started from
from reading
some more computer science related
material
uh you're interested the your interest
in science also was was related
uh to computers in a way because you
were playing with spectrum as a kid so i
guess that one drawn interest in quantum
computing instead came
from a different direction john right
started from physics directly
well that's right simone i started my
career in elementary particle physics
and i worked on that for 20 years
but i changed direction in the mid 1990s
when i heard that at least theoretically
a quantum computer can find the prime
factors of a large number that's a
problem
we think is just too hard with the
computers we have today and the idea
that problems that would otherwise be
too hard to solve can become easy if we
take advantage of abstruse laws of
physics that really fascinated me and i
i still feel that way
and since then i've been excited about
quantum information science both
because we're laying foundations for
revolutionary technologies and
and also because we're opening new
opportunities to advance physical
science so i'm still a professor at
caltech where i've been on the faculty
for 38 years now but
now i'm also an amazon scholar
affiliated with the center for quantum
computing that aws recently launched on
the caltech campus
yeah so you you
uh
you started reading about quantum
computing after you've seen peter shaw
article
and
it it seems that both you and antija
started looking into quantum because of
peter shore i actually started looking
into quantum because of you john
because i was
learning uh quantum computing in your
lecture notes uh back in 1998.
so yeah it's it's it's you know it's
science it's interesting there's a as
you say standing on the shoulders of
giants but also giving each other's hand
and in a chain of people connecting
connecting with each other james what
about you
yeah so um i grew up outside of dc i
think for me my interest in quantum
computing came about from just
um i went to phd and and my advisor gave
me nielsen schwong's textbook and said
read this over the summer and then i
just cut in it was a lot of fun i think
for me my interest in quantum computing
and quantum and computing generally
started with my dad's hobby interest in
computers and i was programming in basic
when i was in middle school so it was a
lot of really fun things to play around
with
and i think for me quantum computing
really came about as a really
interesting synthesis of a lot of ideas
because i learned chemistry and then i
learned mathematics and then kind of
realizing group theory was the best way
to understand a lot of things really
opened a door to really understanding a
lot of things from a mathematical point
of view and quantum computing has been
fantastic with the number of different
areas that you can explore and go into
and see the different branches
and so it's been really really exciting
to to be working in this intersection of
these different fields
and since 2016 i've been a faculty
member at dartmouth and now i'm a amazon
visiting academic where i'm able to
build on this quantum educational
experience that people are coming to
bracket
to amazon broadcast to learn
yeah and i guess we will
we will talk about amazon brackets
later during this conversation so thanks
james catherine
uh yeah so so i um i went to the
university of waterloo for my
undergraduate studies uh which at the
time and still is a very strong center
for quantum computing so as an undergrad
i took
several courses
in quantum mechanics and then also they
had a very nice course in quantum
information
um that i took as an undergrad and i had
the opportunity to do an undergraduate
research experience
and when i submitted the proposal for
that you had to you had to offer two
options with different professors so i
offered one in quantum information and
one in condensed matter and i ended up
actually picking the condensed matter
option and went to graduate school for
that so my graduate studies were mostly
focused on computational condensed
matter um and after a long detour in
that area uh sort of during my post
stock and now at
amazon bracket i kind of returned after
a long time away to studying quantum
information sort of through the shared
connections with computational condensed
matter
and tensor networks
so interesting when were you in waterloo
so i was there from 2008 to 2012.
so we overlapped because i was a postdoc
in waterloo
so
almoud please
yeah i think i probably have the most
non-traditional path to quantum
computing
i loved chemistry as a kid
and actually set my room on fire once
and uh to the dismay of my parents but
once i discovered physics in school uh i
forgot about chemistry completely and
and was fascinated by how you can
understand things in different ways and
describe how different things happen in
nature and so i went to college studied
physics
um
then basically
was mostly focused on paper and pencil
theory
and
to my dismay my parents never let me buy
a computer as a kid they thought it was
a waste of money and so i never really
used a computer until i was in college
and then decided that okay this
programming thing seems interesting but
i'd rather stick to math
so then once i got my masters in
switzerland i decided to do a phd in
computational physics without actually
knowing how to properly program
and that was an extremely steep learning
curve but i got fascinated by really
hard combinatorial problems in physics
also known as spin glasses
and
did a lot of very traditional classical
statistical physics over many years
although here and there i would apply it
to quantum phenomena like for example
topological color codes or any kind of
topological error quotes to compute the
error thresholds
and then this was about the time also
when um
the first quantum devices started coming
online with promises of being able to
solve these hard problems and so
basically like that i slipped into
quantum computing just trying to
understand these systems better and
today i'm here at amazon
basically working closely with our
customers trying to solve really hard
problems using quantum technologies
what about uc money
about me well i studied philosophy so
i'm an imposter here so
but i ended up in quantum computing
as well
uh but it's very interesting to hear
these different stories uh um
there are many ways i suppose to to
reach
a point uh
in in an area which maybe is very
different from the area where we started
when we when we were undergrads or uh
some of you
got interested in quantum computing
because they were interesting computers
some of you got interesting quantum
computers people were interested in
physics and so on is this is beautiful
right and and diabetes
is a fascinating topic also because it's
so much interdisciplinary and puts
together so many different areas and so
many different people and it's really
it's really exciting and fascinating and
you see we we read about quantum
computers every other day in the news
today right and there's lots of talking
about quantum computing but i think that
an important question i want to ask to
to to the room is what what is quantum
computing what are quantum computers and
and please also explain me what
it isn't and i'd start with james
great um for me i for quantum for the
way i like to think of quantum computing
there's new form of technology where you
can leverage quantum resources to do
computation
this is in contrast to semiconductor
technology and standard forms of
computation where you have
classical bits and ordinary bits that
behave under certain type of physics and
then when we have quantum physics that
we are enabled to access more degrees of
freedom coherent variables current
quantum variables and this allows us to
capitalize on the quantum coherence of
these devices
it's important to recognize that this is
not a silver bullet and not everything
can be solved with quantum resources but
it does open the door to solving some
very fascinating problems like has been
already mentioned short factoring
problem and some combinatorial problems
possibly um but i think this is really
the exciting part is to really see what
can we do with these this this new form
of technology that allows us to take
advantage of chronic coherence
right it's interesting so what a
computer is a computer but also is a
device that helps us in the in the
discovery process almost like a
telescope that allow us to see farther
jonah i'd love to hear your perspective
on this
well the way i look at it is
in the 20th century we we learned that
at a truly fundamental level all matter
is governed by quantum theory and that
has already led to technological
breakthroughs like lasers and magnetic
resonance imaging and
integrated circuits with billions of
transistors but really
those technologies are only scratching
the surface of how quantum theory has
altered her view of what's possible in
the universe
when we have a system of many particles
or many quantum bits
interacting strongly with one another
quantum mechanically that's an
enormously complex system it's way too
complex to even describe
using the ordinary language that our
computers today understand and what a
quantum computer will do is control and
exploit that complexity and that will
enable us to process information in a
completely new more powerful way than
we've ever been able to before
but quantum computing is so foreign to
ordinary experience we really have a
very limited ability to foresee what the
long-term implications might be we can
be confident though i think that they're
going to be very profound
but then
how
how might quantum computing be used in
the future
well this is the big open question
um i think uh
we're not sure about that we what we
most clearly foresee
is that we'll use quantum computers to
solve quantum problems to understand how
matter behaves
that'll be important in applications to
chemistry and materials and that's going
to benefit
humankind in many ways but very likely
the most significant applications of
quantum computing are ones we just
haven't been able to conceive of yet
because it's such a different technology
than we've ever had before
it's very beautiful perspective yeah and
so
obviously
building quantum computers is is
challenging right and
um
but why it is so difficult to be quantum
computers and and
and how can you how can you can you
solve this challenge
um
is that one for me okay
well i think they're real or anyone else
you can start drawing let's see what
what the room has to say yeah
well
they're really two huge open questions
the one is how are we going to
scale up the quantum computers we have
today to much larger systems that can
solve
those really hard problems
and once we've done so what'll be the
best way to exploit
the power of those quantum computing
systems and
those are both wide open questions these
are not engineering problems we really
need advances in basic science to make
progress
now you asked why is it so hard and i
think an important part of the answer
is that there's something fundamentally
different about information in a quantum
system than in a classical system like
we use today
and that is that whenever a quantum
system is observed it's unavoidably
disturbed in some uncontrollable way
so if we're going to process quantum
information as we will in a quantum
computer we need to keep it almost
perfectly isolated from the outside
world so it doesn't suffer that
disturbance
and that's possible but it's extremely
difficult and as time goes by we're
getting
uh better and better at that
but
you know it's
uh
far from certain what the time scale
will be for reaching quantum computers
that will broadly benefit society
because we have such hard problems to
solve
so that that's very interesting and
um and a question for earl
you know we read
often about the importance of correcting
errors in quantum computers uh i wonder
if you could tell me a little bit about
these
yeah so quantum computers are very prone
to noise because um
the the components that they're made out
of the individual qubits
are always interacting with their
environments
and so this uh
this this creates errors in the system
and if we don't do anything about those
errors then the output of our quantum
computer won't be reliable so quantum
memory correction is a way of
taking those qubits and turning them
into a logical qubit so a logical cubit
is something that's built out of many
many physical qubits and it's protected
against noise
and i think the really kind of
miraculous thing that also goes back to
peter shaw in the 90s is that error
correction is even possible
and i think it's kind of surprising that
error correction is even possible
because you can't clone a quantum bit
you can't clone a piece of quantum
information this is one of the
underpinning reasons for why quantum key
distribution works
um so you can't clone information so you
can't make many copies of it and rely on
the fact that if you lose one of the
copies the other ones are still there so
you have to do something smarter than
that and that's one of the reasons why i
think call america correction is quite
quite surprising that it even works it's
fascinating fascinating topic and
now i have of course a very
uh very silly question is will i ever
have a quantum computer in my phone
maybe maybe i can
give it a give it a go since i'm an
experimentalist so
i think everybody everybody that is
mildly interested in this topic has seen
the pictures of the quantum computers
that that people have um so typically
you see this sort of
steampunk style chandelier hanging from
the from the ceiling and a bunch of
physicists working around it
and when you see that it's
that is the inside of a what we call a
dilution refrigerator which is an
amazing device that allows you to get
to incredibly low temperatures the
reason we want these
the quantum computer the chip to be at
these low temperatures goes back to what
earl and john was saying were saying
about
error correction and the need to isolate
these quantum systems for from the
environment one of the best ways of
isolating from the environment is just
reducing the temperature
but when you see the size of these
devices of these fridges that we put the
computer in and
all the things that are built around it
it's really hard to imagine that we
would ever be able to put this in a
phone or something that we can carry
around
and and as an experimentalist and
somebody who has worked with these
things i i myself find it very hard to
conceive
having said that
i am you know if you've seen the
pictures of the first transistors that
people developed at bell labs and so on
they were also
not
in any way compact and they were
incredibly
perceived as incredibly complex at the
time like the amount of
a control that people needed to have on
the on the impurities on the materials
and so on was was amazing was
a really challenging at the time so
you know i would say no
i would find it very hard to think of
these things in our phone
but i would keep an open mind because
we've fallen into that trap before and
also another point to make is that some
quantum technologies
so not quantum computing but some other
quantum technologies such as quantum
random number generators so
essentially exploiting
the fundamental randomness that we have
in quantum mechanics to generate high
quality quantum rent random numbers
uh is already integrated in chips and in
phones specifically so
you know maybe maybe we're not
completely maybe it's not completely
science fiction to think of these
technologies being integrated
at some point
that's interesting
james what's your take
i think um
it's a really interesting kind of uh
picking back more for that answer i
think with our phones i mean one of the
things i've tried to do on my computer
is to take software off of it um in the
sense that i don't like it still i don't
have the same build environment on my
computer instead what i do is everything
on the cloud right i mean this is entire
idea of aws right that we don't need to
host anything locally and i think with
quantum computing we might not want it
in our pocket instead we want it cloud
accessible which is how it is now and i
think there's a lot of opportunities to
put more things in the cloud have less
things on our phones just a connection
to other devices so i think there might
be you know a move away from it where
you might have some quantum devices in
your pocket but i think it'd be more
likely to have everything cloud
accessible including
the regular devices so but still still i
i from what i from what i learned during
this conversation is that is so early
for quantum computers still a lot of
uncertainty and
and quantum computers most probably will
have some surprises for us that we can't
even imagine at the moment and this is
fascinating and this is how science
works i guess that
it's very hard to predict the future and
the future may have some some surprises
that are beyond our imagination as well
um
and this is quite a fascinating
conversation what i would like to
to uh to talk
about is uh
you folks are working in quantum
computing at amazon web services
what is edibles doing uh
to to to help customers
uh with with quantum computing with
their quantum computing needs
so maybe i can start so like i mentioned
earlier i work on the amazon bracket
team i am an applied scientist there so
what bracket is doing is trying to
create a sort of framework or tool set
so that anybody who has an internet
connection can access some of the
leading tools in quantum computing so
previously it used to be that for
example if you wanted to try out a new
experimental system you really had to
know and have a relationship with the pi
of the lab who was developing that
system
um and of course these people are very
brilliant they're very kind people um
they love to collaborate with others but
if you don't already have a relationship
with that person it could be hard to
start a collaboration but now
since we're providing access to a
variety of different emerging hardware
technologies in the cloud anybody on
earth who has an aws account can run
their circuit or their experiment on a
cutting edge chrome device and we also
provide a suite of managed simulators
and also a local simulator so if you're
doing something like algorithm
development or you want to try out a new
idea for an experiment before you run it
on a real quantum device you can use a
simulator that we've built that's very
high performance and runs in the cloud
so these simulators simulate the
execution of a computer on classical
hardware before you necessarily want to
try it out on a real quantum device and
that lets you understand for example
like how your algorithm would perform in
an ideal case with or without the
presence of noise um and other
considerations like that
that that's interesting so but and this
these machines are
early
uh quantum computers and from what i
understand uh uh it's gonna take a while
before quantum computing will impact
um
problems
that have
uh commercial commercial value uh i'd
like to to uh to learn more about um
what
approach what what is uh edibles doing
with respect to to hardware and howard
plus is interacting with customers in
quantum computing
so so many so i work at the aws center
for quantum computing and
that's the part of aws that's
responsible for designing and building
our own aws quantum computing hardware
so the main hub for that activity is on
the caltech campus in pasadena with
which we have a close collaboration
and so this kind of complements what
catherine was talking about that the aws
bracket service which is providing
access to third-party hardware this is
this is going to be our own hardware
that we're developing
but to kind of solve all of our
customers needs we're going to need
eventually to build a very large scale
quantum computer and there are many
scaling challenges that we're going to
face
and while university research has
brought us a long way
and indeed compared to my phd days i'm
really amazed at the quality of qubits
that you can get nowadays
but
i think it's also clear that
universities are not going to get us to
the scale that we need to have a
large-scale quantum computer and so
companies are now leading the way in uh
developing large-scale devices with
consistent qubit quality
and aws is starting to bring its
expertise and technology at scale
right
that that's interesting um
but uh
so what i like of
of a service like bracket is that it can
offer a
window
over the state of the art of the
technology and since technology is still
early days and there are many different
ways to build quantum computers
i think that having the possibility of
seeing
different ways that are used to build
quantum computers
it's interesting it's interesting uh
for for for a number of reasons
um so elmwood i wonder i wonder if you
can add
the perspective of of uh how you
interact with customers
sure
so uh let me tag on to what you just
were saying um
that bracket offers a wide variety of
devices i think this is something very
important because we can't just assume
that one particular technology is going
to work really well for a particular
problem and so having the ability to
compare the performance of different
devices on different problems is
something that is very important at this
stage
i don't think it's too early to start
engaging with customers i think it's on
the contrary very important and i agree
with what john said earlier that we
still have to find
the best possible applications for
quantum devices and for that it's really
key to work very closely with customers
and their experts to try to analyze the
the big pain points and problems they're
trying to solve to see where quantum
technologies can help them best and so
we have been working with our customers
very actively in many different areas be
for example in healthcare and life
sciences in chemistry and finance
and we see a lot of problems that come
more mostly from the same areas
for example optimization for example
chemistry for example pharma where you
want to do basically chemistry in a
smaller scale
and and
it's very clear that certain patterns
are emerging that are also educating us
as to where we're missing quantum
algorithms and this is something that is
very important we are focused very much
on the hardware but we also need to
start thinking about what are the new
algorithms we're going to develop such
that we can better solve these problems
and for this i think that having this
whole process driven by our customers
and trying to get them quantum ready at
the same time it's a very important way
to go
right so it's interesting on one side
a challenge is to build the quantum
computer
on the other side a challenge is to
articulate use cases and to design yeah
what migrations that can actually run
on exactly
and the thing is
you know quantum is so weird and
different that we cannot just take a
run-of-the-mill problem and say well i'm
gonna run this now on a quantum computer
because i knew how to do it on a
classical computer we have to take a
step back and think how we're going to
model this problem on a computer
that has quantum effects driving it such
that we can solve it and that's a highly
non-trivial task and this is why
amazon has the quantum solutions lab
where we work closely with our customers
to try to take these real-world problems
and then convert them into a form where
they can be solved on quantum backends
right it's interesting you say that
uh you cannot just take
a problem formulated in the way we
formulate it traditionally for digital
computers and just translate it for a
quantum computer there's a different
process that's interesting so when when
i when i think about quantum computing
today
uh and when i look at what is happening
in quantum computing today i see
a lot of innovation across the board
this innovation uh in in startups
innovation large corporations and an
enormous amount of innovation in in
academia and i think that that the role
of academia uh is still central and
fundamental and i'm curious to know uh
how amazon is working together with
academia to solve some of the challenges
in quantum computing
yeah so perhaps i can say something to
start off with so
as i mentioned earlier the aws center of
computing has its main building on the
caltech campus so there's there's
certainly a close collaboration with
academia through caltech but then
we have various scholars from celtic and
other places
um but also quantum is growing very very
fast and so there's a pipeline of
students with the right skills that is
really really crucial to maintain the
growth of the whole field
and so one of the ways i think that we
can do that and support that growth is
through the internship scheme that we
have which gives the kind of brightest
and best phd students a chance to work
with us on building quantum hardware and
thinking about what kind of protocols
and algorithms we should run on that
hardware
just to follow up on the
the aws center for quantum computing at
caltech
i think that's a partnership that's very
beneficial to both sides
caltech has a thriving community of
scholars working on quantum science and
it's very exciting for people at caltech
to have
in our midst an industrial scale effort
to
solve some of the big technical problems
that'll make quantum computing more
powerful
and for the aws employees who are
embedded
on our campus it enriches their
intellectual environment
to be at a place that's aggressively
advancing quantum science and technology
across a broader front i think that
synergy makes everyone
stronger so important
a
good example of collaboration between
academic industry
right
yeah
i can also chime in um another
interesting way that amazon's engaging
with
academics is through a lot of the
visiting scholar programs
and amazon visiting academics i myself
and visiting academic which is aimed at
pre-tenure early tenure
faculty and it's been a fantastic way
for me to kind of bridge between the
academic setting and the industrial
setting
here at amazon so i think this is a
something that a number of us are
actually have
joint commitments between academia and
amazon so i think it's another way that
it's really engaging on a
person-by-person basis rather than these
large-scale collaborations as well
right so a strong communication channel
between academia and industry and i
think that this is fundamental in an era
like quantum computing
an area where there is of course
engineering problem but also some some
fundamental sciences still to to sort
out and and what what i i get
out of this conversation the the
sentiment is that there is still a lot
of uncertainty about quantum computing
but definitely it's a
it's an area that is moving fast
and where there is a lot of innovation
happening and i'm curious to to get your
opinion about
where do you see this field going
let's say during the next 10 years
well first of all i would say nobody
knows
but it's very likely
that we'll have much more reliable
hardware in 10 years that's going to
make the technology more powerful than
it is today
but
based on what we currently know i think
it's not particularly likely that even
with substantial progress on the
hardware
we'll be able to run the most impactful
applications of quantum computing that
we currently foresee for example to
developing new materials materials or
or chemicals that probably isn't going
to be practical in 10 years but i think
it is likely
that
making use of this technology in the
next five to 10 years
we'll make new scientific discoveries
because we have
tools now for exploring
the behavior
of complex quantum systems that have
never been available available before
and this is the way science often
advances you have new tools new
instruments you can do new kinds of
explorations and you find new things
yes simone i
myself
you know as an ex i'm an experimentalist
so i'm always excited about the
the evolution of the hardware but i
really think that in the next 10 years
what i'm really watching and what i'm
really exciting is excited about is
watching
a much wider
range of people interacting with quantum
computers i think
really
and this has happened in classical
computing as well right people imagine
applications from a high level but then
you get
a wide range of people that are experts
in completely different areas and start
playing with the machines trying little
things trying little algorithms
and just the ex that exploration drives
drives advances you know we especially
in this area that we're now with these
quantum computers that are still
relatively small as
john said they probably
we think it's going to be a while until
they can do something like run shore's
algorithm
but there's this huge intermediate space
between
being able to run shores algorithm in
what we have now that is virtually
unexplored because the machines are not
perfect they
sometimes they they might have early
machines might have error correction
that only corrects like some types of
errors and
we just don't know what will be
what we will be able to do with these
with these machines on the on the short
scale particularly as
domain scientists you know as
experts on on
other completely disconnected areas of
science start looking at this and and
appreciating or having insight into what
these machines can do for them
so that's what i find super
interesting and i'm looking forward in
the next 10 years or so
yeah so as as john said it's hard to uh
kind of look into a crystal ball and see
the future but if we kind of look back
into the past um then what we see is
that a decade ago
the quality of qubits was much much
lower certainly much lower than the
quality that was needed to really
demonstrate error correction and so for
me that's the most kind of exciting
thing about the moment that we're at the
moment because
we have reached this point where the
quality of quantum computers is at that
threshold of which you can expect to
build a logical qubit
and for that logical qubit to be better
than the individual physical qubits that
you built it from and so i think that's
going to be the most interesting thing
over the next decade
i think that we will see a logical qubit
i'm going to say that i think we'll see
a logical qubit that is better than
physical qubit and i think we might even
make a bit more progress beyond that so
we're going to make it many times better
than a physical qubit we're going to
demonstrate some logical operations and
we're going to try and build further
yeah but i mean what is a logical qubit
what is a logical cubit okay
um
yeah so logical cubit is a cubit that's
protected from noise and as i kind of
mentioned earlier it's built out of lots
of physical qubits
and so um
let me if i can kind of give a classical
analog if i say that instead of i want
to store the bit zero or the bit one and
instead of storing zero i store
the string zero zero zero with each of
those zeros stored in separate locations
and i saw one as one one one with each
of those ones stored in separate
locations and if the information is
damaged at any one of those locations i
can still retrieve the original message
and so that's that's classical error
correction and quantum error correction
is kind of a quantum analog of that i
take my quantum state and then i
delocalize it across many physical
qubits across many different locations
if i if i lose some small fraction of
those or only a small fraction of a
damaged then i'll be able to
reproduce the
undamaged logical qubit and so in a
quantum computer when we talk about a
large scale voltron quantum computer
we're constantly doing this through
every single con
clock cycle constantly refreshing the
the logical cuber
thank you so hey catherine i'm curious
about your perspective on this
um yeah so i think uh my my two main
views for the future kind of already
covered in the sense that it's super
exciting that we now have such quality
qubits that we can really start
exploring the algorithms that have been
discussed and developed like since the
90s really um
and it's a situation a little bit
analogous to me to machine learning
where sort of like the fundamental
algorithms that people use in machine
learning were developed like quite a
long time ago even in some cases in the
70s and 80s but the quality of
technology to run them on was not there
and then once the technology developed
to the point where we could apply those
algorithms is probably everyone's aware
we saw like a real flowering of
applications for machine learning huge
improvements and the algorithms were
able to use so i'm excited for hopefully
a similar process to occur with quantum
computing and then similarly as we also
know there's been huge uh growth in sort
of the talent
entering that field um that field being
machine learning partly because we're
able to now provide practical
applications um there's a lot of
opportunities for people to find good
positions in that field so i think the
really exciting thing that hasn't
already been mentioned for me is that
we're going to see a new generation of
students professionals um
if you like like quantum engineers
entering the field who will be able to
bring new insights that we haven't yet
been able to imagine um so i'm really
excited to see what sort of the quantum
computing generation after us is going
to be able to accomplish
yeah quite quite interesting and also
it must be said that
quantum computing
is just a
a portion of of this larger broader uh
area which is quantum technologies right
and i i'd be curious to
um to hear a little bit about
other quantum technologies in addition
to quantum computing
so you want to i'll i'll take that
because that's that's close to my heart
since i've been working on other quantum
technologies
for quite a while so as you said there's
quantum technologies uh broadly speaking
the field is called quantum information
science
and quantum computing is one branch of
that it's it's maybe right now the the
better known branch but there are other
branches so
another branch is quantum sensing or
quantum metrology
that is very active and essentially it's
using some of these
quantum effects and
uh
maybe the more sophisticated quantum
effects of things based on um
some of the same techniques that we use
in quantum computing
but to make things like better clocks or
make sensors that are
are correlated to each other in
interesting ways and
so people people are doing a lot of
developments for
gravitometers and accelerometers and
things like that which have huge
technical implications
the other area is quantum communications
or quantum networking
and that is
i like to think about it as quantum
computing being the stationary qubits
and quantum communications dealing with
the flying qubits
so
just like in classical
classical information we have the the
computing resources and we have the
communication resources we have the same
we can map that onto onto what happens
in quantum technologies
and it's been known for quite a while
that we can do things in quantum
communication that are pretty
interesting so one of the main
applications is called
quantum key distribution
where you can exploit the
inherent randomness
and the
that exist in in quantum systems to
create
perfectly secure uh
correlated numbers that can then you be
used for cryptography so quantum key
distribution essentially you distribute
secure keys
uh between different parties
and that is really based on things like
the quantum no colonial theorem that was
mentioned before so
if you're transferring a trans if a
qubit is going from a to b and somebody
tries to measure it it's going to
inevitably disturb it in some way and we
can use quantum tools we can use our
knowledge of quantum systems to detect
those interferences
other really fun things are
quantum teleportation for example where
you can it sounds like science fiction
but it's it's a real thing we can
transfer
the exact quantum state from one
location to another
without
signaling the contents of that quantum
state in some sense uh that's not a very
good explanation but
but really that's that is what hap is
what's happening
um
and another thing that i already
mentioned is of course these uh true
random numbers uh or quantum random
numbers
it turns out that randomness is an
incredibly important resource and
technologies you know people spend
a lot of
effort and money into generating
perfectly random numbers and streams of
randomness at high speeds
and that is something that quantum
mechanics excels at
uh and we can do all sorts of
interesting things people have already
integrated these things these
techniques into chips into phones and
and that area is just growing
uh very fast as well so
so yeah quantum technologies is lots of
things of which quantum computing is
only a part
so we're very excited to look at
all the implications of these
technologies and how they connect to
each other
what do people do with randomness
yeah a good question they they do so
there are all sorts of
applications for randomness uh
i i can't remember who said this but
somebody said randomness is too
important to leave to chance
uh so
it does turn out that we we need
randomness for all sort of things on the
maybe connecting to computing we need
randomness for
uh for things like monte carlo methods
monte carlo methods are
computational methods where you
you use randomness to sample from a
distribution for example and i won't say
anything else because i'll get it wrong
and helmut will
go after me but
um
but that is a very important uh
computational uh role of randomness
uh insecurity randomness is extremely
important you you use randomness every
day your browser uses it
to create uh short-lived cryptographic
keys
to generate unique ids for example to
generate
all sorts of things so it's it's a very
important
technology in fact
thank you so i suppose that
i
uh i'm thinking
about
a career in quantum computing at amazon
what words of wisdom
do you have for me
well of course people from a wide
variety of backgrounds can contribute to
advancing quantum computing that
interdisciplinary character is
part of why it's so exhilarating as
simoni and tia have emphasized
there are roles for people who
understand the hardware or the software
the applications and so on if you don't
have a background in quantum physics i
think it's very helpful
to have some appreciation for the
language spoken by quantum systems it's
different from the language that
ordinary computers use
it's the language of a field of
mathematics called linear algebra
and familiarity with the principles and
methods of linear algebras that's very
empowering for anyone working in the
quantum industry and also a knowledge of
probability and
those things are useful for other
reasons too
but apart from that my advice is
if you find quantum physics confusing or
hard to understand don't be discouraged
by that i've been a theoretical
physicist for
45 years and i'm getting confused all
the time
that just comes with the territory but
just persevere and a better
understanding will come
you i cannot i can only second that john
um i only understood quantum really when
i had to teach it at the university to
be really honest i had no idea what i
was doing as a student
and probably even now you know who was
saying that
if you claim to understand quantum
mechanics uh you you actually haven't
understood it was was feinman or
it's supposed to be bore i think but who
knows okay
yeah so i would also say specifically
for roles like mine
where
on our team we work very closely with
software engineers
and people who who are very smart and
have a very strong background in
classical computing but aren't
necessarily quantum experts it's very
helpful to have some classical
computational skills of your own there's
obviously a lot of room in this field
for people who are focused more on pen
and paper techniques um but day to day i
do a lot of coding on classical
computers so
having sort of a mixed background in
both quantum physics and
just regular classical programming can
be very helpful it's useful to help
understand what about quantum computing
is surprising or odd uh if you already
have a strong background in sort of
classical computation and the other
thing um
that i think we've kind of been alluding
to here is that um
since quantum computing is such a new
area and it's very mathematical it also
helps to have strong communication
skills to communicate with other people
who have a strong technical background
but maybe aren't quantum experts or
people who are interested in quantum
computing in general how it could affect
their industry their lives but are not
experts in physics or computation in
general
right and i guess communication skills
is something related to all science
right because in science you you want to
collaborate with other people you want
to
to work with other people and with
different skills and
and being able to talk
with people is it's important and
in science uh
one plus one is always more than two
right
yeah i i would build on what catherine
has said and say that you know if you
think of
how for example how
what we're doing at aws you you have
this huge range you go from
building the hardware where you need
people that know about uh cryogenics and
fpga electronics for control for example
you know
then to physicists that are more on the
superconductors
the theorists that help
understand you know the the error
correction protocols and how that
interacts directly with the
with the material systems and and
in those controls
and then you
you keep moving towards the the
computational side you have to look at
the application so you need people that
are done
subject
domain experts on
say biology chemistry uh operations
research you know all of these things
so these
sometimes people ask you know what
skills do i need to get into quantum
computing and i tend to think that a lot
of it at this point is about
combinations of skills do you know this
and that and can you make those
connections
um
so
so i think there's there's a huge room
for for people who are curious and want
to contribute to the field
also adding to maybe to what john says
i would say
if you unders want to understand what is
weird about quantum systems you need to
understand statistics really well you
know what
because a lot of it is in the
correlations between systems a lot of
the surprising effects are about
correlations
so maybe that's one skill i would say is
is very uh useful something i would
build
upon thank you
so when i was um
i guess when i came out my undergraduate
degree i'd learned a lot of quantum
physics but i hadn't learned anything
about quantum computing yet and i
decided that's what i wanted to go into
so i had a phd interview scheduled um
and i realized i had to very quickly
learn something about quantum computing
so
a few days before i picked up a copy of
some lecture notes by
someone called john
i don't know if you've heard of him
um anyway
at the end of yours asked many questions
which
were exactly questions that came up from
this set of lecture notes so they were
very helpful i don't know if i would
have actually passed my interview for
some first lecture notes so highly
recommend those for anyone that's uh
starting out in quantum computing
thanks
if i can just add a little bit at the
end i think one of the or maybe not the
end but add a little bit more i think
one of the things that's been kind of
underlined repeatedly throughout the
conversation is how many roles there are
and how the growth of the field no one
really knows where it's going to go and
this level of excitement around quantum
computing that i think now is the time
if you're interested in the quantum
computing to go learn to go explore to
go apply to see what you can do see how
you can build your skills into something
that will be useful and contribute to
the ongoing effort i think it's a really
exciting time so i think this
my advice would be just go for it and
try and scale yourself up and all the
ways that everyone said already but just
you know get to work and start
yeah if i might tag on to that james
you know quantum is different quantum is
weird and the only way you're really
going to get it is if you just play with
it and so i encourage everybody to just
experiment you know hop on
bracket for example and use the
different back ends
try to come up with
better ways of solving problems because
a lot of the innovation often happens at
the intersection of different
disciplines and so having somebody come
in that is not an expert in quantum but
just starts experimenting might unlock
some of new solutions applications etc
etc that you know we
physicists or quantum researchers
would not even have thought of just
because we're looking at everything
always from the same angle and so i
think that you know go play roll up the
sleeves hand some keyboards and get it
going
interesting so having
a an experimental approach
uh to
learning quantum computing that's that's
what you're saying
yeah
yeah
i mean it's it's if i just may add to
this the last thing you know it's like
driving a car you can't read a book and
sit behind the wheel
you gotta practice and so it's the same
thing here you know sit down start
coding up
interact with these devices and see what
you can do sorry for interrupting you
but no no what i learned is what
learning is uh
quantum computing is a very
interdisciplinary area
and
it's very important specifically because
of this interdisciplinarity that people
that
maybe have nothing to do with quantum
computing itself get engaged
and can contribute to the field itself
because they can bring a new perspective
maybe that people are
working in the field do not necessarily
have
yeah so well thank you
thanks to my colleagues for joining and
for this uh for this very thoughtful
discussion
for those watching make sure to check
out our website
amazon.science to learn more about
quantum computing and other areas of
customer obsession science at amazon and
bye now
you